[Laughter]
we talked about people chasing you with
bombs and backpacks yeah i've had lou in
here with his chips that's good
using these chips yeah i like i i don't
know if you know this about me but i
like the chips oh gosh i'm so glad you
know we he was in here one time we had a
rick glassman who's uh
yeah yeah so rick was in here and he
started eating the chips and rick has
that also a lot of comedians have it
yeah and so rick just turned him and
said this is not [ __ ] funny i'm just
angry yeah you're just making me mad it
um
you know
it's a rage i i wanted to say we were
talking about show business and you were
talking about the the success in show
business and i too have been you know in
the business for a while and had my ups
and downs but i could say this i could
always always get arrested
[Laughter]
it's a good joke what's going on in
burbank nobody on there no i think they
they turn it down sometimes so it
doesn't what is lou muted burbank i
don't know louis muted in murbank i also
should mention and i don't know if this
bothers you the girl in the center the
lady in the center with just crossed her
legs a grown woman yes the grown woman
i'm sorry did i use the wrong in my
pistol i've learned that not at all i
love you and i'm if you don't mind i'll
just mention it and no i like it
correctly i'm so afraid i'm so afraid i
do it too i say girl but i said girl i
don't anymore because she she schooled
me on it like no no i'm getting mad like
there has to be a space for people to
you know when when i'm with a non-binary
person
i [ __ ] up their pronouns all the time
and i'm so excited to use their pronouns
right and i go oh god dawg damn dave
do you ask them their pronoun when you
approach somebody do you say what do you
no but you don't no i don't i probably
should but i don't but i you know i will
i've worked with a couple people who are
non-binary who are they them yeah and
and then i get so excited and then i i
mess up and i get so mad and always
they're like
don't worry about it you're trying you
know it's like going to france and that
you're supposed to like try a little bit
of french so at least that and then
we'll speak english with you but they
want to just know you're on track you're
making an effort but that was that's
what i think about and you said that i
think you're more afraid to offend
someone he's really afraid to i'm really
i'm nervous i don't want to talk or open
my mouth i don't want to see somebody i
don't know how do they that's the side
of the progressive side that i consider
myself progressive but that i get
frustrated with is that there's no
space you know and i do think people are
gonna i do think people are gonna be
more patient and you know what i mean
but the the not the internet no yeah but
the internet is it isn't the whole world
it is a lot of people but the the thing
is where they get their information i've
been saying to sarah about being
open-minded thing is i've explained to
her because like you i have
you know i and i'm this isn't passing
the [ __ ] but like when you grow up as a
male in this country we're also
loaded with all sorts of toxic garbage
that we don't i you know i'm only now
learning about that and going oh yeah i
guess i guess that was the wrong way to
do things it's like men can't have
feelings men can't cry only babies what
are you a girl you you know i mean
everything it's so it's like it's hard
to
you know there's a little bit of deep
programming that has to happen so what
that's the thing that i think
has been frustrating sometimes is
feeling like no one gives
you got to just be up to speed
immediately that's gonna be the hardest
thing in life i'm trying very hard to
like learn but all of us you know this
journey of life is supposed to be about
change and growth and i think that our
humanity
the natural instinct is just to hang on
for dear life to whatever you what we
know to what you know and that's the
normal and everybody wants to go i hope
it was the way you know even in the
simplest terms people go that was music
yeah this is not the music right you
know it's a big band sound that's what
it's all about and we're but but that's
what we try to do and do you think
you're different today than you were 10
years ago really different
yes you do
uh yeah yeah i yeah i've changed
so much and i always feel like if you
you know i can look at old stuff i've
done and be and like love it like i
loved my show the sarah silverman
program but it's like
totally problematic but i still love it
for what it was and i understand that
comedy is an evergreen but
and and that's why i mean that's why
like you're still so relevant is like
you're always changing with the times
you're always
even just i mean even if we're just
talking about on like a technological
level like you're always up to date on
the latest technology and the latest
things
and um but you know that comes out of my
neurosis i fomo is oprah coined it you
know fear of missing out is there a new
way how can i reach
like how can i get all the way to
burbank from vancouver
is dating a republican because there's
no good-looking men in sherman oaks
that's what she told me
and she's keeping her apps open where
how how far do you have to commute to
date the republican
um he's in he's in santa clarita but i
don't totally know where that is so he
always comes to me
and do you put the alarm on when he
comes over um yes
can his can his pickup fit in your
driveway
and that's not an innuendo that's not an
inner window i was not an innuendo i
think it might drove a pickup truck you
just turned the whole audience
[Music]